كما نقل موقع اكسيوس وقناه سي بي ان نيوز
عن مسؤولين امريكيين واسرائيليين ان لقاء
مرتقبا اليوم في العاصمه البولنديه وارسو
سيضم رئيس المساد الاسرائيلي ديفيد برنياع
ومدير وكاله المخابرات المركزيه الامريكيه
ويليام بنز ورئيس الوزراء القطريه الشيخ
محمد بن عبد الرحمن الثاني لمناقشه صفقه
جديده محتمله لاطلاق سراح الرهائن من غزه
ونقل موقع اكسيس عن مسؤولين اسرائيليين ان
استمرار مشاركه مدير المخابرات الامريكيه
في المفاوضات امر بالغ الاهميه للتوصل الى
اي اتفاق جديد وتوقع هؤلاء المسؤولون
الاسرائيليون ان يكون الاتفاق على شروط
صفقه جديده محتمله اكثر صعوبه كما نقلت
قناه سي بي ان نيوز عن مسؤول ام امريكي ان
لقاء وارسو ياتي ضمن الجهود التي تبذل
لضمان اطلاق سراح عشرات الرهائن في
غزه ننوه بهذا
الخبر عن مستشفى سوركه الاسرائيلي اعلان
عن هذا المستشفى يقول انه استقبل
8 جنديا
اسرائيليا مصابا جراء القتال في
غزه الان ينضم الينا من الخليل الدكتور
بلال الشبكي رئيس قسم العلوم السياسيه في
جامعه الخليل دكتور بلال اهلا بك لنبدا
ب الدور الامريكي من جانب هناك وزير
الدفاع الذي يزور اسرائيل ومن جانب اخر
هناك هذا اللقاء ل اجهزه الاستخبارات في
وارسو في
بولندا هل فعلا اعطت الولايات المتحده
الضوء الاخضر لاسرائيل للاستمرار في
العمليه هل تريد هذا ام تريد التهدئه
والهدنه الانسانيه واطلاق سراح
الاسرى مساء الخير استاذه ليلى حقيقه
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه حاولت يعني
منذ اسابيع ان تشكل يعني غطاء جديدا
لاسرائيل من خلال دعوات يعني ان يكون هناك
جدول زمني وان يكون هناك وقف لاطلاق النار
على المدنيين وما الى ذلك من تصريحات
امريك هي حقيقه لم تكن صحوه اخلاقيه من
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه ولا اعاده
اكتشاف لما يجري في قطاع غزه ولذلك يعني
كان هناك دائما سعي امريكي للتركيز على
هذه النقطه من باب حمايه اسرائيل من
الخارج الان الامور ربما قبلت من اطراف
امنيه اسرائيليه وعسكريه من مجلس الحرب
الاسرائيلي في مقابله هذا الطرح الامريكي
انه هذا الطرح الذي يشير الى امكانيه
انتهاء الحرب في غضون اسبوعين بمعنى مع
نهايه هذا العام اصبح يعطي دافعا جديدا
للفصائل الفلسطينيه في قطاع غزه بمعنى ان
الفصائل الفلسطينيه لو كانت على قناعه
بانه هم في الربع ساعه الاخير من الحرب
سيبدو اكثر صلابه وسيصبح اكثر تشددا
وبرايي انه الحديث الذي تم اليوم من قبل
وزير الدفاع الامريكي باظهار انه لا يوجد
سقف زمني هذا هذا لا يعكس حقيقه ما يجري
داخل الاروقه السياسيه وخلف الكواليس هذا
يعكس تخوف الولايات المتحده الامريكيه مما
بات يظهر من تباينات ما بين الحديث
الاسرائيلي والحديث الام امريكي بمعنى
انهم لا يريدوا ان يوصلوا رساله للفصائل
الفلسطينيه بان الحرب يعني قاب قوسين او
ادنى من الانتهاء وبالتالي يعني يمكنكم
الصمود اكثر ولا يمكن لاسرائيل ان تحقق اي
انجازات تذكر في هذه الفتره لذلك هذا جزء
من محاوله اسناد اسرائيل هذه المره لانه
هم مدركين انه اسرائيل حتى هذه اللحظه لم
تحقق شيء يمكن من خلاله ان تحافظ على
صورتها في منطقه الشرق الاوسط لكن دون ان
يعني ذلك باي شكل من الاشكال ان الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه مستعده لتحمل استمراريه
الحرب بصورتها الحاليه لذلك برايي بين
هاتين النظرتين نظره الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه التي تريد المحافظه على المظله
الدوليه من التاكل وبين نظره الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي الذي لا يريد ان يعطي الفصائل
الفلسطينيه امل بامكانيه انتهاء الحرب
وبالتالي يزيد من الضغط النفسي والضغط
السياسي والامني على الفصائل الفلسطينيه
خرجوا ب فكره جديده وهي تقسيم العمليه
العسكريه الى مراحل وهذه المراحل
بالمناسبه يعني نقشت من قبل خبراء عسكريين
على شاشه الجزيره وقالوا اكثر من مره انه
في في العمليات العسكريه الانتقال من
مرحله الى مرحله لا يعني شيء اذا كانت
المرحله الاولى لم تحقق اهدافها فتبدو لنا
ان الانتقال الى المرحله الجديده من قبل
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه او ما تدعو
اليه الولايات المتحده الامريكيه هي
محاوله مساعده اسرائيل للاستمرار في الحرب
هذا ما تريده هذا ما يريده مجلس الحرب
وتحديدا بنيامين نتنياهو في مجلس الحرب
لكن دون دون ان تؤدي استمراريه العمليه
العسكريه الى مزيد من التاكل في المظله
الدوليه والى فقدان الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه ما اسماه بايدن مركزها الاخلاقي
في العالم هذه المرحله الجديده التي يتحدث
عنها بعمليات اقل وبعمليات ما اسمها
عمليات جراحيه بالاضافه الى تصغير الاهداف
الاسرائيليه لتتحول من القضاء على حركه
حماس واستعاده المحتجزين الى القضاء على
قيادات حركه حماس والضغط على ح حماس من
اجل اعاده المحتجزين وهناك فرق شاسع ما
بين الهدفين او ما بين الهدفين الجديدين
والهدفين الذان اعلنا في بدايه هذه الحرب
ولكن دكتور بلال كما ذكرت ما يجري خلف
الابواب الموصده شيء وما يعلن شيء اخر في
هذه الحاله كان هناك حرص من جانب وزير
الدفاع الامريكي على الا يظهر ان هناك اي
خلاف بين تل ابيب وواشنطن فيما يتعلق
باستمرار الحرب ولكن التوقيت بالنسبه
لواشنطن شيء والضغوط من داخل اسرائيل شيء
اخر يعني مع توالي هذه الصور الفيديوهات
التي تابعناها اليوم خصوصا وهذه المناشدات
من الاسرى انفسهم الى اي حد تؤثر في
الداخل الاسرائيلي وخصوصا ان الاهالي ربما
يتفاعلون بصوره اكثر خشونه مما فعلوه في
السابق هذه نقطه مهمه برايي انه الفصائل
الفلسطينيه حين تبدا بضخ الكثير من
المعلومات حول وضع الاسرى والانجازات
العسكريه والفشل في الاداء من قبل المؤسسه
العسكريه في قطاع غزه هي تدرك ما يجري
الان في الشارع الاسرائيلي في الشارع
الاسرائيلي لدينا الان فئتين الفئه الاولى
فئه صلبه متماسكه تلك اليمينيه التي تريد
استمرار الحرب باي ثمن ولا تلقي بالا لاي
اعتبارات مرتبطه بالمحتجزين اما الفئه
الثانيه وهي التي تضع اولويه اعاده
المحتجزين هي المهمه هذه الفئه غير
متماسكه بمعنى ما زالت رخوه هناك من يريد
ان يدفع ثمن عالي جدا ربما يؤدي الى
انتهاء الحرب وهناك من ينادي بضروره ان
يكون هناك هد مؤقت الفصائل الفلسطينيه ما
تعمل عليه الان من خلال ضخط كل هذه
المعلومات هي تريد ان ان تدفع هذه الجبهه
او هذه الفئه الثانيه الى التماسك اكثر
اذا تماسكت فعلا سنجد ان هناك سياسيين بما
فيهم اولئك الذين يوجدوا الان في مجلس
الحرب مستعدين للاستثمار في هذه الفئه هم
الان لديهم تخوف يعني حتى بيني جانس الذي
يبدو اكثر مقبولي ل لدى المجتمع الدولي
لديه تخوف انه هذه الجماعه وهذه الفئه
التي تنادي باطلاق سراح المحتجزين لم
تتماسك بعد الى الحد التي الذي يمكن
اعتبارها قاعده جماهيريه صلبه يمكن
الاستناد عليها في تحويل السياسات وبرايي
انه الامور تتجه باتجاه تماسك هذه الجبهه
مع زياده الاخفاقات وهناك جماعات او اوساط
في المؤسسه العسكريه الاسرائيليه بدات
تسرب معلومات تزيد من تماسك هذه الجبهه
بالاضافه الى المستشفيات وما تظهر من
معلومات يعني بشكل متكرر كل يوم تزيد ايضا
من تماسك هذه الفئه نعم وعلى ذكر
المستشفيات ما كنا نقلناه قبل قليل عن
استقبال مستشفى اسرائيلي جديد لدفعه جديده
من المصابين هذا الامر يتكرر على العموم
اشكرك دكتور بلال
الشبكي شكرا جزيلا لك من الخليل رئيس قسم
العلوم السياسيه في جامعه الخليل